well first of all you guys are fashion
icons and i know we've been doing a lot
of
you know zoom chats are you wearing
sweatpants
underneath your top half
can i get my leg up adequately no let's
stand up oh
tim yes give it to us tim oh oh
wait
hilarious okay well congratulations on
season two of making the cut
you guys are one of the most dynamic
duos on television and i have to ask you
know just as
friends and co-workers is there anything
you've learned about
yourself through each other like heidi
what is one thing that tim has taught
you
uh many words like one of them is
titillating
[Laughter]
many many words no but you know tim and
i
we share the same passion for this
industry you know
still after so many years being in this
industry
from when we first started you know i
think you know our heartbeats for it
we love each other care for each other
we have each other's back
you know we've also been in the most
vulnerable moments together which really
bonds you in a different way
you know it's also one thing if you do
one season of work with someone or you
go on a photo shoot that you meet
someone
but spending almost two decades together
you know we've had many sweaty palms
holding each other's hand backstage
somewhere
terrified of going out having to do
something
to you know i don't know designers leave
us in the middle of the night and we're
like not knowing what to do you know i
don't know so
we had many make it work moment
you know also you know jumping ship from
project runway
making this decision of us together you
know trying something new that we always
wanted to do
you know also was like a beautiful
moment that i don't know
probably would have never happened with
someone else like you know like tim and
i
it's like we have the same goal and
mindset
and at the end of the day we want to
find great talent
we love and breathe for this so when we
see a magical beautiful show and we have
you know amazing art coming towards our
way we're like
yes you know this is why we're here
we're here to find great people
shine a light on them and let them have
their time
you know and here we have 10 amazing
designers for this season
and you know they're fantastic and it
made me
every time realize over and over again
why we're doing this
absolutely and while we're still doing
it you know yeah
yeah tim what is one thing you would say
that you learned from heidi
well heidi has made me a more complete
person
i'm a more confident and happier person
to be perfectly honest
and she's really taught me how to live
in the moment
and be not just content with that but
really to celebrate it
and while we have those sweaty palm
moments we also have moments when we
can't
stop laughing yeah and and the more we
laugh the more we laugh
yeah yeah it's just this moment
where they have to stop the tape and
it's like you have to stop guys because
the designers think you guys are
laughing at them and we're not
you know it's not really not it's like
because something happened and then it's
just like and then you get into this
tizzy of like you can't stop and then
like you guys have to stop but it's like
the more you tell us
it's the most plan
i'm the luckiest guy in the world to
have money in my life the luxurious oh
that is so good
oh my gosh this season you guys have
brought two
new judges of course our canadian winnie
harlow
and jeremy scott given they both have
incredible backgrounds what do you think
they
add this season i mean
to me um winnie is like the
absolute it's girl i mean she's a
supermodel but i feel like
you know she has the finger on the post
yeah she is everywhere in the world
every designer is dressing her she's
doing all the campaigns
and i remember when i was doing modeling
more
many many years ago you just know a year
ahead of time
what is happening what people are doing
so she does have also a different
insight
you know into the fashion industry and i
feel like jeremy
is kind of like who they all want to be
you know because he
has the the sensibility of making art
and also having
you know the power to make beautiful art
because it's just within his blood
but then also how do you relate that to
a t-shirt
so it's not like a boring t-shirt you
know
you know but if it's just a t-shirt it's
not just a t-shirt because you can tell
this is mustino and he makes sure
that you know for a good price you can
be part of mostino and you can make it
fabulous and this is what we're looking
for on making the cut we're looking for
great fashionable pieces that you know
people are going to fall in love with
around the world and actually spend
their hard-earned money on and buy
you know yeah i know totally last season
you guys took designers around the world
of course this season due to the global
health crisis it's in la you have to
stay in one city
um do you think that people are finally
seeing la as as more of a
fashion capital i feel like ellie
doesn't get the respect
well they should be seeing la's as a
fashion capital certainly
um i i've been citing fashion history
before world war
ii this country was a nation of copiers
we copied the couture collections in
paris
and the only place there where there was
any creative work happening in fashion
was in hollywood on in the film industry
in fact
the early graduates of of parsons
fashion program which began in 1906
all went to hollywood because that's
that's where the industry was wow
yeah the whole world the whole world
would look at the hollywood stars
you know being you know going to the
movie premieres looking
fantastic you know and tailored
beautiful outfits you know
so i mean when fashion before
okay was maybe interesting for people
who are really into fashion but the
world was not necessarily looking at
that
but hollywood and the stars and starlets
they looked at them everywhere yeah
uh heidi lastly season 16 agt
what the heck are you guys looking for
now
what's left we're looking for special
people
you know i think at the end of the day
people who create emotions
you know i mean on agt for me also it's
like i'm looking for someone who blows
me away and i've seen a lot of things
and it's the same on making the cut
we're looking for someone who is special
who can produce special things
there is a lot of talent out there
there's a lot of you know
also people who are willing and wanted
so bad but not everyone i feel like
has that special something so you know
it is a privilege
to be able to look through all these
people and see what they do
hear what they have to say and who they
want to design for and where they want
to be in the world
and then to help them achieve their goal
it's
a super satisfying feeling you know to
help these people boost their career
awesome and we feel the same way about
making the cut yes
thank you guys so much for your time
that went by so fast you guys are so fun
thank you
thank you take care